nice hat Thanks oh I like it limited
edition in stores
we are revamping our patreon page that
means everything from the new photos
you've seen it's been posting around a
bunch of new rewards and stuff like that
and also we've been working on a really
cool new video also if you want
continuity with the last shot I should
be in front
yeah and I'll just step into like this
and like they start talking while you
walk up or help me to the person okay
anymore so what do you want to start
with them the actual challenge here is
so there's this thing called tether that
we've been working on for a long time
has it probably seen the shorts we've
been working on this thing for so long
and every single year we talked to some
movie producer or something like that
and they're like oh tell me more what's
tethered and the funny thing about it is
that almost every single year changes
exceptionally talented group of
filmmakers we got JJ junior TV spiels ii
got DD we get we got little George Lucas
George it's just regular toward or just
actually have George Lucas game three
two one action every single year we kind
of continue to grow as filmmakers and
each time we look back on our previous
work and previous versions of it we see
a lot of room for improvement it's
gotten really small it's gotten really
huge now it's kind of finding it's kind
of middle ground right now where it's a
really cool idea of really cool project
something that would be possible for us
to shoot well not tear in the model
apartments take all this junk off
doing some vibe stuff at the moment so
they just added Wireless update but you
have to update it with a wire still per
name that's a good sign
I've had a couple failed prints we try
printing it small nothing too
complicated no idea we try to make it
bigger and again just fail there's never
been any particular reason for it but
the feeder that pulls in the material
ends up clogging up trying to figure out
why this is if anybody knows let me know
so I was looking in the comments for the
video or announced proposal apparently
it sounded like I said I proposed to
Ivan no offense to all you Ivan's out
there I'm sure your lovely people Ivy is
the girl I proposed to I guess I need to
articulate a little bit more and be
louder it's tiny microphones I can pick
up all my sounds yeah it it filming them
all isn't the best but still the printer
should be able to print it it's it's
just having how my wife's having it so
lucky I got bad yeah yeah that's pretty
nasty well maybe I should see if I can
use that program to ramesh the whole
thing and just simplify things it's just
supposed to be an x-wing cockpits in
order to determine what it is that's
causing it is it the model is it the
printer I think it's model because I can
easily say this the worst model I've
ever given you to print is the unlucky
guy that has to haul shopping cart oh my
god I need to get back to the studio I
have a bicycle here's a cart we have a
tow line let's do this
oh we're getting pretty good at this we
are starting a new tradition here and
this is the first of hopefully many
which is